A Serbian farmer shows up at the
hospital, beer bottles shoved inside him.
He blames Albanian attackers.
By the time this lie finishes spreading,
800,000 people will
be ethnically cleansed.
And Putin is using this exact
playbook in Ukraine right now.
This is History vs. Hype.
I'm about to show you how one man's lie
became the blueprint for modern warfare.
How Serbian intellectuals weaponized
legitimate historical
grievances to justify genocide.
And how those same tactics are tearing
apart the world today.
This isn't about taking sides.
This is about how real history gets
twisted into deadly propaganda.
May 1st, 1985.
Georgya Martynovitch
rushes to a hospital in Kosovo.
The 56-year-old Serbian farmer has a beer
bottle lodged in his rectum.
It's broken inside him.
The injuries are severe.
His story.
His story, two masked Albanian attackers
Two masked Albanian attackers
tied him up and tortured him.
They wanted to drive him off his land.
But Colonel Novak
Ivanovich investigates the case.
His conclusion.
Martynovitch is lying.
Martynowić is lying.
The medical evidence shows the injuries
were self-inflicted.
Now in any normal world
that would be the end of it.
One bizarre incident, case closed.
But this wasn't just any province.
This was Kosovo.
And for Serbs, Kosovo isn't just land.
It's sacred ground.
Instead of accepting the medical
evidence, Serbian
intellectuals see an opportunity.
216 prominent academics sign
a petition in January 1986.
Listen to what they wrote.
The case of Georgya Martynovitch has
become that of the
whole Serb nation in Kosovo.
They compared it to
medieval Turkish torture.
They called it proof
of Albanian genocide.
And the Serbian public,
And the Serbian
public believed every word.
they believed every word.
Because this wasn't
just about one farmer.
For Serbs this was about
For Serbs, this was
about losing their Jerusalem.
Now you might be wondering, Jerusalem?
Why would a province in
Yugoslavia matter that much?
The answer takes us back 600 years to a
battlefield, a choice and a
story that shaped an entire
people.
To understand what happened next, you
need to understand what
Kosovo means to Serbian
identity.
And it's not nothing.
Kosovo contains some of Serbia's most
sacred Orthodox monasteries.
The Chani, built in the 14th century.
Grasanica, with its
stunning Byzantine frescoes.
The Patriarchate of Pej, seat of the
Serbian Orthodox Church.
But above all, there's
the Battle of Kosovo.
June 28th, 1389.
June 28th, 1398.
Prince Lazar chooses to fight the Ottoman
Empire, knowing he will likely die.
According to Serbian epic poetry, he
chose heavenly glory over earthly defeat.
For 600 years this story
For 600 years, this story
shaped Serbian identity.
The idea that Serbs would rather die than
surrender their faith and freedom.
By 1998, Slobodan Milosevic stood on that
same battlefield and
told a million Serbs.
Through the play of history and life, it
seems as if Serbia has, precisely in this
year, regained its
state and national dignity.
This isn't fabricated emotion.
These are real historical sites.
Real cultural memory.
Real fears about demographic change.
By 1981, Serbs were only
13% of Kosovo's population.
Many were leaving for jobs
in Belgrade and elsewhere.
The question haunting Serbian
intellectuals was simple.
Are we losing our sacred heartland?
But here's where
history gets complicated.
Because Albanian families have their own
600 year old memories of this place.
Ottoman tax records from 1488 show mixed
Albanian Serbian
populations already living together.
Both peoples had called
Kosovo home for centuries.
Moving around, following work, fleeing
wars, intermarrying.
Even that sacred battle of Kosovo.
Prince Lazar's army included Albanian
warriors fighting alongside
Serbs against the Ottomans.
They weren't ancient enemies.
They were allies facing a common threat.
And those Serbian monasteries?
They're absolutely real
and historically significant.
But they were built in a region that was
already ethnically mixed.
Serbian researchers studying one district
in the 1930s found something fascinating.
706 families who'
706 families who'd
lived there for generations.
And 1,819 families who
were recent immigrants.
Both Serb and Albanian
families showed the same pattern.
The uncomfortable truth.
The uncomfortable truth, both peoples are
Both peoples are indigenous to Kosovo.
indigenous to Kosovo.
Both have legitimate historical claims.
Both have suffered real injustices.
But in the 1980s, Serbian intellectuals
decided that
acknowledging this complexity wasn't
politically useful.
So they simplified the story.
And simplified stories
make excellent propaganda.
Meet the man who turned these complex
realities into simple lies.
Spyridion Gopsević, the father of
Serbian political ethnography.
This guy published academic research
proving that all
Albanians in Kosovo were actually
Albanianized Serbs.
Brilliant scientific breakthrough, right?
Except German scholars quickly exposed
him as a complete fraud.
His supposed research journey through
Kosovo never happened.
He just copied other
books and made things up.
Gustav Weigand, the leading German Balkan
Gustav Weygand, the leading German Balkan
expert, called his work "a mass of crude
lies".
The Serbian government's response?
The Serbian government's response.
They funded the lavish
German translation anyway.
Because the lies supported their
territorial ambitions.
This is how legitimate cultural concerns
get weaponized into academic fraud.
By the 1980s, Serbian intellectuals were
mass-producing books about Albanian
genocide against Serbs.
Systematic persecution, cultural
Systematic persecution.
Cultural extermination.
extermination, a conspiracy to
A conspiracy to drive
out the Serbian people.
drive out the Serbian people.
Here's the reality check
that destroys this narrative.
Between 1981 and 1978, there were exactly
In 1981 and 1978 there were exactly 5
inter-ethnic murders in all of Kosovo.
5.
Two Albanians killed Serbs.
Three Serbs killed Albanians.
Kosovo had the lowest
crime rate in Yugoslavia.
That's not genocide.
That's barely a statistic.
Look, were some Serbs genuinely concerned
about their future in Kosovo?
Absolutely.
Were there real tensions over jobs,
language rights and
cultural preservation?
Of course.
But when intellectuals take legitimate
anxieties and turn them
into genocide fantasies?
That's not scholarship.
That's manufacturing
consent for ethnic cleansing.
Fast forward to 1999.
NATO bombed Serbia for 78 days.
Serbian propaganda immediately frames
this as unprovoked western aggression
against innocent Serbs
defending their sacred land.
But let's talk about what actually
triggered those bombs.
By March 1999, Serbian forces had already
displaced 300,000 people.
They were forcing refugees to destroy
their identity documents at the border.
Why?
So they couldn't prove
citizenship and return home.
The Rasak massacre.
The Razag massacre.
23 Albanian men
separated from their families.
Lined up, shot at close range.
Not soldiers.
Not fighters.
Just Albanian villagers
executed for being Albanian.
Remember Martinevic and his beer bottle?
It started with one man's
lie about being victimized.
It ended with 800,000 real victims being
ethnically cleansed.
Those Serbian monasteries they claimed to
be protecting still standing.
Those Albanian families they claimed were
threatening Serbian survival.
Driven from their homes in cattle cars.
Now here's where this story becomes a
threat to all of us.
Putin was watching.
Putin was learning.
Putin was copying.
2008 Russia invades Georgia.
2008, Russia invades Georgia.
Explicitly citing Kosovo as president.
2014, Putin annexes Crimea,
2014 Putin annexes Crimea, referencing
referencing Kosovo
independence in his speech.
2022, Russia recognizes breakaway
territories in Ukraine
using the exact same playbook.
Same historical grievances.
Same protection of minorities narrative.
Same academic authorities
vouching for ancient injustices.
Same humanitarian
intervention to save your people.
Russian bots today spread
the exact same Kosovo myths
Kosovo myths Serbian
Serbian intellectuals
perfected 40 years ago.
40 years ago.
The template doesn't just work.
It's scalable.
And next time it might be your historical
grievances they weaponize.
So what's the real lesson here?
It's not that Serbian concerns about
Kosovo were illegitimate.
Many of them weren't.
It's not that Albanian families didn't
also have valid claims to their homeland.
They absolutely did.
The lesson is how smart people take
complex, legitimate grievances
grievances and turn them into simple
and turn them into simple, deadly lies.
deadly lies.
Real monasteries become
proof of eternal ownership.
Demographic anxiety
becomes genocide fantasy.
Academic fraud becomes government policy.
Government policy
becomes ethnic cleansing.
And that every step, educated people who
should have known better
chose the convenient lie
shows the convenient lie
over the complicated truth.
The next time someone tries to sell you a
war, listen for this pattern.
war listen for this pattern.
Ancient grievances with
real historical roots.
Academic authorities vouching for
simplified narratives.
Victim stories that justify any response.
Ask yourself, what
complexity is this story erasing?
What legitimate
concerns is it weaponizing?
And what do they want me to do about it?
Because once you see how legitimate
grievances get turned into propaganda,
propaganda you can't unsee
you can't unsee it.
it.
And propaganda, once
exposed, loses its power to destroy.
Even propaganda that starts with
something as real as sacred ground
as real as sacred ground and as fake as a
and as fake as a farmer's lie.